[Musique]
politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre émission politique du
dimanche soir sur Radio sensation
diffusée aussi sur TV 78 épisode 223 ce
soir mon invité le conseiller régional
RN d'Île-de-France Laurent Morin
[Musique]
ique
Laurent Morin bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
aussi délégué départemental du
rassemblement national dans les Yvelines
on va évoquer avec vous plusieurs sujets
ce soir la présidence du RN d'abord le
nouveau plan régional d'adaptation au
changement climatique aussi ou encore le
Pass Navigo dans dans l'actualité locale
mais d'abord on va parler de la victoire
de Giorgia melloni en Italie la
présidente de Fratelli Italia a remporté
avec une coalition allant de la droite à
l'extrême droite les élections
législatives elle va prochainement
former son gouvernement alors d'un côté
les patriotes italiens arrivent au
pouvoir mais de l'autre côté votre
principal allié la Ligue chute avec 8%
des voix alors comment est-ce que vous
analysez vous au RN ces résultats et
bien d'abord je me félicite de
l'émergence de mouvements politiques à
l'échelle du continent européen dans les
différents États membres des forces
politiques qui sont
sur le créneau que nous nous défendons
ici également en France avec avec le
rassemblement national je pense que
il y a une sorte de face à face entre
d'un côté une fuite en avant de l'Union
européenne dans sa politique qui se
voulait fédéraliste mais que l'on peut
considérer maintenant comme une
politique impérialiste puisque
auparavant elle laissait une certaine
autonomie aux États membres dans la
gestion d'un certain nombre de
compétences et aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que l'Union européenne veut en
fait s'accaparer toutes les compétences
ne laissez plus aucune autonomie plus
aucune liberté aux États membres sur un
certain nombre
de sujets je pourrais en citer en citer
deux le le sujet sanitaire par exemple
avec des projets de résolution et de
règlement sur
le déploiement d'un centre européen
concernant la prévention et le
traitement des des menaces sanitaires à
la place donc des compétences des États
et puis il y a un autre un autre exemple
sur les sujets environnementaux avec la
volonté de l'Union européenne d'imposer
partout le déploiement d'éolienne contre
la vie des peuples des différents pays
et bien face à cela face à cette à cette
volonté d'imposer un certain nombre de
décisions les peuples européens
réagissent se soulève démocratiquement
on l'a vu en Suède avec lors des
élections législatives qui se sont
déroulées il y a quelques semaines
l'émergence des démocrates de Suède qui
est un parti sur le même créneau
politique que celui du rassemblement
national ou de Fratelli d'Italia
vous pensez que cette victoire elle est
due au enfin contre c'est un message
envoyé à l'Europe de la part des
Italiens ou c'est contre la gauche et le
centre italien ah je pense qu'il y a il
y a certainement un peu des deux mais je
pense que la manière dont l'Union
européenne
traite les États membres on a vu juste
avant d'ailleurs en Italie et avant ces
élections législatives que la présidente
de la commission
Ursula wanderlayenne
menaçait menaçait l'Italie de rétorsion
financière si le vote ne correspondait
pas à ce qu'elle souhaitait c'est
d'ailleurs la même pratique qu'elle
mette en œuvre vis-à-vis de la Hongrie
vis-à-vis de la Pologne c'est absolument
scandaleux que les pays soient soumis à
ce chantage de l'Union européenne assez
assez menace et je pense que les
Européens n'acceptent plus cela et c'est
donc la raison pour laquelle en Italie
il y a eu ce vote massif pour pour
Fratelli l'Italia et la coalition de
droite je note qu'en France les
élections législatives
ont aussi montré une très forte poussée
de notre de notre camp national ceci est
aussi dû à la déclinaison politique en
France par le gouvernement et par le
Président de la République des
politiques qui sont imposés par l'Union
européenne donc il y a d'un point de vue
démocratique une réaction des peuples
face à cette fuite en avant de l'Union
européenne et il y a aussi une réaction
parfois dans la rue nous avons eu le
mouvement des gilets jaunes en France il
y a des mouvements massifs au Pays-Bas
de mobilisation d'agriculteurs il y a
des mouvements massifs de mobilisation
en République tchèque donc moi je vois
je vois cette cette prise de conscience
des peuples européens de manière de
manière tout à fait positive et je pense
que au regard de l'insistance de l'Union
européenne à vouloir aller toujours plus
loin dans le fait de s'accaparer les
compétences des pays de nier leurs
identités de nier leur
leur mode de vie de nier leur volonté je
vois effectivement que je pense que
effectivement cette cette dynamique de
réveil des peuples européens ne
s'arrêtera pas alors en Italie genre
Meloni était plutôt sur la ligne
politique d'erics Zemmour vous vous
étiez plutôt proche de Le RN de la Ligue
de Matteo Salvini alors du côté des
partisans de reconquête on estime qu'il
faudrait que c'est l'exemple parfait
pour remettre sur la table une union des
droites alors pour vous au RN c'est
toujours non bah je pense que le débat a
eu lieu lors de l'élection
présidentielle lors de des élections
législatives je pense que ce débat a eu
lieu Éric Zemmour a présenté son projet
d'union des droites Marine Le Pen a
présenté sa stratégie son constat ses
solutions et je pense que le peuple a
tranché a très clairement dit que
la manière dont Éric Zemmour voyait
la réalité politique la manière dont il
pensait trouver des solutions n'étaient
pas du tout
ce que ce que les Français attendaient
et je pense même que
paradoxalement il défend l'idée de
l'Union des droites mais paradoxalement
il l'a peut-être par sa brutalité dans
cette campagne il l'a peut-être tué
cette cette idée d'union d'union des
droites et je pense que aujourd'hui aux
élections législatives il n'a pas fait
de second tour il n'a pas député
et je pense que le rassemblement
national et le seul mouvement politique
à pouvoir à pouvoir incarner l'espoir
non seulement des des électeurs de
droite en général mais de manière
beaucoup plus large des français puisque
nous notre objectif c'est quand même
d'atteindre aux élections nationales aux
élections présidentielles aux élections
législatives les 50% plus une voix
l'objectif c'est de c'est de conquérir
le pouvoir et nous avons réussi à le
faire lors des élections législatives
puisque même sans avoir instauré la
proportionnelle que Emmanuel Macron
avait promis d'instaurer même sans cette
proportionnelle nous avons
nous avons atteint les 50% dans de
nombreuses circonscriptions ce qui nous
a permis de constituer le groupe le plus
puissant que nous n'avions jamais
constitué à l'Assemblée nationale avec
ce groupe de 89 députés qui pèse
énormément qui a déjà enregistré un
certain nombre de succès au mois de
juillet avec des amendements qui ont été
adoptés et qui ont permis aussi de
mettre en minorité la majorité relative
d'Emmanuel Macron ce qui visiblement lui
lui pose un problème aujourd'hui
par rapport notamment à des projets
qu'il peut avoir on en parlera tout à
l'heure mais la réforme des retraites
semble être un point absolument crucial
de ce point de vue là le système
présidentiel français n'est peut-être
pas le plus propice vous me direz à
l'union des droites mais pour les
européennes 2024 est-ce que ce ne serait
pas un choix judicieux selon vous vous
parliez de ce mouvement donc qui est en
train de cette dynamique en tout cas qui
est en train de se lancer en Europe sur
l'Europe des nations que vous défendez
Éric Zemmour défend également cette
Europe des nations ce qui serait pas
judicieux de proposer une liste commune
en 2024 mais nous nous accueillons
depuis d'ailleurs le soir du premier
tour des élections présidentielles nous
accueillons tous les militants et tous
les adhérents de reconquête qui veulent
nous rejoindre sur la base des constats
et des propositions que nous faisons
d'ailleurs beaucoup de députés européens
élus en 2000 donc élus il y a 6 ans sur
la liste de Jordan Bardella sont passés
depuis chez reconquête oui au moment de
l'élection présidentielle quand vous
dites beaucoup ça la concerne trois
trois députés européens trois ou quatre
qui visiblement
on peut faire ce constat après cette
séquence électorale on fait le on fait
le mauvais choix d'un point de vue
politique je le regrette pour eux parce
que évidemment c'était il s'agissait
d'éléments d'éléments tout à fait
intéressant de notre mouvement politique
mais malheureusement le choix n'a pas
été couronné de succès donc nous nous
accueillons bien évidemment tous ceux
qui veulent travailler avec nous qu'ils
soient de droite de gauche de reconquête
mais par contre voilà
brutalité des exemmour et le fait qu'il
a qu'il qu'il tape sur le le
rassemblement national pendant toute la
campagne à laisser des traces à laisser
beaucoup de doutes sur son intention
véritable et donc il n'est pas possible
de travailler ensemble en tout cas c'est
ce qu'on déclarait les deux candidats à
l'élection de la présidence du
rassemblement national qui aura lieu au
mois de novembre que ce soit Louis Aliot
ou Jordan Bardella on dit tous les deux
que voilà avec les cadres avec certains
cadres de de chez reconquête il n'y a
pas la confiance suffisante pour
travailler pour travailler ensemble donc
les prochaines élections
européennes seront les prochaines étions
et les sciences électorales
alors il y a avec là il y aura les
sénatoriales 2023 dans dans la région
Île-de-France et dans les Yvelines
notamment nous c'est là donc c'est des
élections indirectes
indirect c'est ça
après la Hongrie la Pologne la Suède
l'Italie est-ce que toute cette
dynamique avec
c'est avant toute cette dynamique en
Europe l'Europe des nations que que vous
défendez peut-elle gagner en 2024 ou
vous êtes confiant mais moi je suis je
suis très confiant en l'avenir et je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que je
pense que de manière générale en Europe
et en France en particulier je pense que
de plus en plus de citoyens vont être
victimes des politiques qui sont menées
et je le regrette j'aimerais que les
politiques soient différentes nous nous
battons pour que nous puissions mettre
en œuvre des politiques qui défendent
l'intérêt général qui défendent la
souveraineté des nations qui défendent
une croissance qui soit adaptée aussi
aux problématiques environnementales et
malheureusement tout l'inverse est mise
en oeuvre par ceux qui par ceux qui nous
dirigent donc je suis je suis convaincu
sur un certain nombre de sujets que ce
soit les sujets migratoires médicaux
environnementaux je suis convaincu que
de plus en plus de Français vont
malheureusement être victimes de cette
de cette de français et d'Européen de
ces politiques là et que un encablement
inéluctablement il prendront conscience
que nous faisons les bons constats que
nous proposons les bonnes solutions
qu'ils nous rejoindront le mouvement est
déjà et déjà bien engagé puisque nous
avons quand même lors de ces élections
présidentielles et législatives battus
des records en termes de pourcentage et
en terme de voix je pense que le
mouvement va s'amplifier je pense que
nous arriverons au pouvoir nous sommes
je pense l'alternance à Emmanuel Macron
et à sa politique à la politique
mondialiste et européiste et je pense
que dans les autres pays européens la
prise de conscience va s'amplifier
également et que nous sommes en capacité
peut-être dès 2024 pour les élections
européennes de pouvoir de pouvoir
réaliser là aussi des scores historiques
en votre partie le rassemblement
national vous l'avez évoqué désignera
son futur président le 5 novembre
prochain lors d'un congrès ça se passera
la Mutualité à Paris alors deux
candidats sont en lice Jordan Bardella
députés européen et Louis Aliot maire de
Perpignan s'il n'y a pas vraiment de
différence sur la ligne politique entre
les deux ça va plus être un choix de
personnalité magasin oui nous avons nous
avons dans cet exercice de démocratie
interne suite à la volonté de Marine Le
Pen de se consacrer exclusivement à la
présidence du goût du groupe de députés
à l'Assemblée nationale
nous avons effectivement la présence de
deux candidats deux candidats de qualité
qui ont un parcours exemplaire au sein
du rassemblement national qui s'estime
mutuellement que les adhérents aiment
tous les deux effectivement le choix le
choix est un choix très très intéressant
parce que si effectivement sur la ligne
politique nous sommes tous synchronisés
sur sur la ligne politique et la note
depuis des années il y a malgré tout des
différences notamment de personnalité et
j'ai personnellement moi fait le fait le
choix puisque je suis membre du Conseil
national élargi de notre mouvement
politique et donc j'étais en capacité de
pouvoir parrainer l'un ou l'autre ou
d'autres même candidats pour se
présenter à la à la à la présidence du
parti et donc j'ai souhaité parrainer
Jordan Bardella je voterai pour Jordan
Bardella et je fais campagne pour lui
car j'estime que
j'estime que d'abord il a il a rempli
parfaitement ses missions la mission
d'intérim voilà comme président par
intérim pendant toute la campagne
présidentielle et législative il a
également totalement assuré ses missions
lorsqu'il était candidate de liste aux
élections européennes en 2019 donc
j'estime qu'il faut garder cette cette
équipe qui gagne qu'il faut poursuivre
avec cette dynamique et continuer dans
cette dans cette voie là et puis
il y a une autre une autre raison qui
qui je pense est importante
c'est que Louis Aliot émerge de
Perpignan et maire d'une grande ville il
est implanté il est il est très apprécié
évidemment dans son dans son secteur
mais il a une charge très importante
avec cette gestion d'une ville d'une
ville aussi importante que celle de
Perpignan et je pense que sans voilà
sans sans
on les estimé ou sous-estimé ses
capacités mais je pense que Jordan
Bardella et peut-être plus en capacité
d'être disponible pour la présidence du
parti d'une part mais aussi pour être
présent dans dans les médias parce que
évidemment quand on est président d'un
parti comme comme celui qui est le nôtre
il faut pouvoir défendre ses idées
quasiment au quotidien j'allais dire
dans les vidéos à Paris je pense que
pour alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
avec les moyens technologiques modernes
on peut on peut faire beaucoup de choses
mais voilà moi je pense que Jordan et la
personne qui qui va nous permettre de
poursuivre cette dynamique il a déclaré
que nous prendrions le pouvoir c'est un
peu ce que je vous disais précédemment
je pense que effectivement nous allons y
arriver et qu'il faut être en capacité
de se préparer à cette prise de pouvoir
de renforcer les équipes de nous
professionnaliser professionnaliser
jardin de Bordella indiqué qu'il y
aurait une école des cadres qui serait
qui serait mise en place donc voilà je
je fais campagne pour pour Jordan Barla
pour l'élection à la présidence du
rassemblement national et si le RN
souhaite l'emporter en 2027 un des
prochains défis ça sera d'améliorer les
scores en Île-de-France Marine Le Pen il
y a fait 27 % des voix au second tour
c'est le score le plus faible de toutes
les régions de France il faudra que la
nouvelle direction prenne cela en compte
selon vous ce que vous allez également
porter je vous êtes candidats d'ailleurs
pour siéger au prochain conseil national
du parti oui tout à fait c'est
effectivement une stratégie que je
défends depuis un certain nombre
d'années je pars du principe que on ne
pourra pas gagner une élection
présidentielle si nous n'améliorons pas
nos scores dans notamment dans dans les
zones urbaines dans les régions dans les
régions importantes de France et
notamment dans la dans la plus grande
région de France l'Île-de-France nous
progressons nous progressons fortement
en région Île-de-France notamment dans
les dans les départements de grande
courant de grande couronne mais pas que
nous avons pu obtenir le résultat de
député élu en région en France qui
n'était jamais jamais arrivé une en
Seine-et-Marne voilà une en
Seine-et-Marne et une en Essonne donc
nous progressons nous nous implantons
nous commençons effectivement à
enregistrer des succès importants sur
des zones géographiques de plus en plus
vastes mais je pense qu'il faut
continuer dans cette stratégie parce que
parce que encore une fois les résultats
de l'île de France avec la masse de
population que cela représente il faut
pouvoir
ne pas ne pas encaisser un retard un
retard important que nous ne pourrions
pas combler dans dans les provinces
françaises où nous faisons des des
scores importants donc moi je défends
cette idée et j'espère qu'effectivement
cette stratégie pourrait être
éventuellement mise en oeuvre prise en
compte avec peut-être des moyens
spécifiques dédiés à la région
Île-de-France pour pour amplifier notre
notre implantation et nos scores et nos
résultats donc l'actualité également une
nouvelle loi asile et immigration devra
être je suis à l'Assemblée début 2023
sur cette question le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron a fait savoir
qu'il souhaitait une meilleure
répartition des immigrés sur l'ensemble
du territoire alors selon l'association
France Terre d'Asile l'urgence est de
garantir plutôt un vrai accueil digne à
tous ces immigrés vous RN vous demandez
toujours un référendum sur la question
c'est toujours la position du parti
alors évidemment nous demandons un
référendum sur la question de
l'immigration se faisait partie du
programme de Marine Le Pen c'était une
proposition phare de sa campagne
présidentielle et puis nous proposons
toute une série d'autres mesures comme
par exemple la suppression du droit du
sol l'expulsion des étrangers qui sont
clandestins ici en France l'expulsion
des délinquants étrangers après après
avoir purgé leur père leur peine dans
les dans les prisons françaises donc
effectivement le gouvernement nous
trouvera toujours sur sa route pour nous
opposer à sa volonté de de d'accueil de
migrants en France bien souvent des
migrants qui rentrent illégalement en
France je vous parlais tout à l'heure
des déclinaisons des politiques
européennes c'est une déclinaison ça
aussi des politiques européennes puisque
la volonté d'implanter
des migrants dans les territoires ruraux
cela découle directement du pacte asile
émigration qui qui est un pacte de
l'union de l'Union européenne donc nous
avons entendu parler en Bretagne je
crois dans la commune de Callac d'un
projet d'un projet horizon qui qui
souhaitait implanter je crois une
centaine de migrants dans un petit
village breton et bien nos élus locaux
se sont mobilisés et pas seulement nos
élus locaux des élus aussi d'autres
barres politiques se sont comment ça se
mobiliser les habitants eux-mêmes se
mobilisent parce qu'il est inacceptable
que qu'un que que qu'une parce qu'en
l'occurrence le projet horizon ce sont
des des personnes privées qui qui
essayent de mettre en place ce projet
donc il est inacceptable sans la
consultation des des Français et des
habitants de cette commune que ces
projets puissent voir le jour parce
qu'on sait très bien quelles sont les
conséquences de cette immigration
massive qui ne s'intègre plus qui ne
s'intègre pas parce que parce que nous
avons déjà dépassé très largement le
seuil acceptable de l'immigration en
France et cela pose ensuite les
problèmes que nous connaissons dans les
zones urbaines dans les banlieues
français c'est-à-dire un changement de
nos modes de vie des problèmes de
sécurité donc évidemment nous nous
opposons nous nous opposerons toujours à
cette à cette immigration que les
Français ne veulent pas dont les
Français ne veulent pas ils l'ont ils
l'expriment depuis des années dans dans
de multiples sondages études d'opinion
dans une grande majorité dans leur
grande majorité les Français ne veulent
pas ne veulent plus de cette de cette
immigration car ils ont le sentiment que
dans de nombreuses zones françaises ils
ne sont plus chez eux et que la loi
n'est plus respectée donc c'est très
clair c'est une priorité pour le
rassemblement national ça reste bien
évidemment une priorité c'est le moment
de passer à la deuxième partie de
politique on va s'intéresser maintenant
à l'actualité du Conseil régional
d'Île-de-France très bien
l'hebdopolitique
toujours avec Laurent Morin délégué
départemental du rassemblement national
dans les Yvelines et conseillers
régionales de la région
Île-de-France la région qui a voté le 22
septembre dernier un plan d'adaptation
régionale au changement climatique c'est
la première région à le faire c'est un
plan nécessaire pour faciliter la vie
des Franciliens dans les années à venir
alors ce plan qui était très complet
était constitué d'un certain nombre de
mesures de bon sens la majorité de
Valérie Pécresse a enfoncé un certain
nombre de portes ouvertes et évidemment
il était difficile de s'opposer à un
plan avec des mesures aussi évidentes
que celles qui ont été proposées je
pense par exemple à l'implantation de
Fontaine à au maintien et à la
plantation d'arbres au déploiement de la
géothermie au déploiement de cuve de
récupération d'eau de pluie voilà tout
cela ce sont évidemment des mesures de
bon sens que nous climatisation dans les
trains les bus aussi voilà donc tout ça
ce sont des mesures de bon sens nous le
proposions déjà nous-mêmes au
rassemblement national auparavant et
nous avons bien entendu voté
favorablement ce plan d'adaptation au
changement climatique je j'insiste sur
le mot adaptation parce que en vérité
évidemment c'est bon pour pour
l'environnement de notre région c'est
bon pour les Franciliens mais en vérité
sur la problématique du changement
climatique ça n'aura que très peu
d'impact la question les enjeux ne si tu
passes sur la politique d'adaptation
elle se situe sur la sur la politique
d'atténuation des émissions de gaz à
effet SR et moi je regrette je l'ai déjà
dit un certain nombre de fois et je
regrette que les sujets
importants et cruciaux sur ce sur cette
problématique de l'environnement ne soit
que très peu ou très rarement traité car
en vérité ce qui ce qui pose un problème
au niveau au niveau climatique au niveau
environnemental ce sont d'une part les
politiques énergétiques qui sont mises
en place et on pourra y revenir et
également les politiques économiques
quand on défend sans arrêt des
politiques de libre-échange quand on
signe sans arrêt des traités de
libre-échange avec des pays du monde
entier pour faire venir des produits de
l'autre bout du monde ça n'est
évidemment pas pertinent c'est même
absurde d'un point de vue économique
d'un point de vue environnemental et
c'est là que se situe le problème et moi
je regrette que Valérie Pécresse la
Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
présidente de la première région
économique d'Europe présidente d'une des
régions les plus importantes
économiquement du monde ne disent pas de
manière plus puissante qu'elle s'oppose
elle aussi à ce que à la prolifération à
la multiplication des traités de
libre-échange ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point c'est effectivement
les politiques énergétiques qui sont
mises en place qui ont un impact majeur
sur sur notre environnement et en cela
là aussi Valérie Pécresse avait déclaré
je crois en 2018 qu'elle était plutôt
favorable à la réduction du parc
nucléaire en France qu'il fallait
progressivement sortir du nucléaire
développer des énergies renouvelables et
bien on constate aujourd'hui que c'est
une erreur une erreur sur en termes de
pouvoir d'achat en termes de
d'indépendance énergétique et en termes
environnemental donc évidemment
nous nous prenons effectivement le
redéveloppement du nucléaire car il
s'agit d'une énergie décarbonée il
s'agit d'une énergie sûre alors elle a
aussi un certain nombre de défauts mais
si on fait le bilan de l'ensemble des
énergies
je pense que c'est l'énergie qui nous
procure le le qui nous procure d'abord
des tarifs énergétiques bien moins
importants que les autres énergies ne
font pas d'autres pays parce qu'on ne
dépend pas d'autres pays qui nous
procurent aussi une sécurité en
approvisionnement sécurisé une
indépendance énergétique et qui répond
de manière tout à fait correcte aux
problématiques environnementales et
notamment des missions de gaz à effet de
serre parce que quand on remplace le
nucléaire comme le souhaite l'Union
européenne comme le souhaite Emmanuel
Macron par des énergies renouvelables du
type éolien ou photovoltaïque en vérité
on constate que c'est un fiasco
l'Allemagne a choisi de remplacer
totalement son parc nucléaire par
l'implantation d'éolienne dans tout son
dans tout le pays et aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'ils font et bien ils
rouvrent des des usines des centrales
qui qui consomment du du charbon et de
la et qui émettent des gaz à effet de
serre donc le l'éolien est un fiasco et
je regrette là aussi
la volonté d'Emmanuel Macron d'implanter
des éoliennes terrestres et maritimes
comme cela a été fait sur la côte
atlantique et j'ai d'ailleurs une pensée
pour pour tous les habitants de la côte
atlantique parce que il se retrouve
maintenant avec un horizon bouché et en
fait la politique d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est ça c'est boucher notre horizon sur
tous les sujets qu'il a qu'il traite et
je le regrette et nous le combattons
vous parliez tout à l'heure de réduire
donc les les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui n'étaient pas forcément le
l'objectif direct de ce plan
d'adaptation au changement climatique ça
m'amène à parler des transports en
commun notamment le Pass Navigo la
Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France Valérie Pécresse a indiqué
quand l'État est vu l'augmentation donc
justement des prix de l'énergie dont
vous parlez elle sera contrainte elle
d'augmenter le prix de du Pass Navigo de
25 euros ce qui le qui l'amènerait donc
à 100 euros par mois il n'avait pas
augmenté depuis 5 ans c'est vraiment
envisageable selon vous un pass Navigo à
100 euros par mois bah écoutez ça va pas
améliorer le pouvoir d'achat des
Franciliens c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire qu'ils sont déjà très touchés par
par l'augmentation générale des prix
moi je voilà je suis en contact
forcément avec avec énormément de
divinois et qui qui me disent qu'il ne
s'en sortent pas donc ce sera un coup
dur supplémentaire pour pour leur
pouvoir d'achat
[Musique]
ce qui ce dont il faut avoir conscience
sur cette sur cette volonté de Valérie
Pécresse d'augmenter le Pass Navigo
c'est qu'elle prend prétexte de
l'inflation actuelle qui est réelle qui
aggrave effectivement la situation
financière de
collectivités et du syndicat
Île-de-France mobilité mais en vérité ce
problème existait déjà avant et a été
noté d'ailleurs par les élus du
rassemblement national depuis des années
dénoncée par les élus du rassemblement
national depuis des années la situation
est par la Cour des comptes également
qui qui pointait du doigt effectivement
la la dégradation de la situation
financière de d'idfm
il y a une dette très importante de
l'ordre de 18 milliards d'euros chez
dans ce syndicat et je pense qu'en fait
c'est la conséquence de choix qui qui
ont été qui ont été très coûteux et très
malvenus au niveau de la gestion des
transports en Île-de-France je pense par
exemple au projet pharaonique qui ont
été décidés par par Valérie Pécresse
concernant le Charles de Gaulle Express
ou un certain nombre de lignes du par du
Paris grand Express donc ça c'est ce
sont des des projets qui ont été coûteux
qui prennent beaucoup de retard et qui
expliquent que la situation financière
de
IDFM se soit dégradée et qui explique du
coup en vérité que aujourd'hui elle soit
contrainte à augmenter les tarifs du
Pass Navigo moi j'aimerais aussi
puisqu'on parle de transport avoir une
pensée pour tous les usagers des
transports qui qui voient leurs offres
réduites qui ne voient pas
d'amélioration sur la sécurité
a une étude de l'institut Paris Région
qui indique que quatre France quatre
usagers du des transports sur 10 ont
peur d'agression de vol dans les
transports dans les transports en commun
il n'y a pas que les usagers d'ailleurs
il y a aussi les agents les agents de la
RATP les agents de la SNCF qui se font
agresser donc je pense qu'il faudrait
concentrer peut-être plus
ses moyens sur l'amélioration de la
sécurité la l'amélioration de l'offre
l'amélioration de la ponctualité plutôt
que sur des projets pharaoniques qui si
on prend le cas par exemple de Charles
de Gaulle Express n'est qu'un n'est
qu'un doublon du RER existant donc et
qui coûte effectivement très cher merci
beaucoup Laurent Morin d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes délégué
départemental merci du rassemblement
national dans les Yvelines et nous on se
retrouve bientôt pour un nouveau numéro
de l'hebdopolitique sur Radio sensation
[Musique]